many of those repair and resiliency
reactions depend upon NAD and and all of
the accumulated insults
um involve you know losses to get to the
NAD system so I think there is a use
case for nicotinamide Drive side in
human health it may be in fact more
important as we age there's lots of
clinical trials involving NR to test
these hypotheses
so I think aging is a
um so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video I had
the opportunity of speaking with Charles
Brenner a professor at the department of
diabetes and cancer metabolism at the
Beckman Research Institute of the City
of Hope National Medical Center
he has contributed to the fields of NAD
metabolism and is passionate about
demystifying aging research I hope you
enjoy our conversation
so hi Charles thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the sugar Science
Show
great to meet you thanks thanks it's
nice to be here great so um well I
brought you onto the channel today to
talk about your research and your
knowledge
um in particular about NAD metabolism
and so I thought we could begin that and
I know it's quite a big question but if
you're able to somehow summarize
um what is NAD metabolism and why is it
important in the body
great uh thank you it's a it's a great
opportunity to um
and you're going to hear some noise in
the background here
unfortunately but um NAD refers to four
coenzymes that are the central catalysts
of metabolism
and so I like to think of metabolism as
the collection of all the reactions that
convert everything that we eat into
everything that we are and everything
that we do so it's not just converting
food into ATP biological energy but it's
converting food into biosynthetic
intermediates in order to make
everything in our cells allow us to
replicate our DNA make RNA and protein
make lipids and repair all of the
molecules in our body so all of that is
metabolism and
um not in every single metabolic step
but
um
within two or three uh steps of of every
metabolic step there's movement of high
energy electrons
and so that the source of the high
energy electrons for life on this planet
is the Sun
and
um
NAD in the oxidized form NAD plus
captures
electrons in processes like glucose
oxidation amino acid oxidation and lipid
oxidation forming nadh
and
um
then
um nadh
is a high drive or an electron donor to
a number of reactions
um nadh
contributes lots of electrons at the
inner mitochondrial membrane to generate
ATP by oxidative phosphorylation but the
equally important components of
metabolism are biosynthetic
and that is mostly done by a pair of
coenzymes called nadp and nadph
they're made from NAD and
um they're essential for making all the
nucleotides in your body
they're essential for making all the
lipids
um in your body and and for detoxifying
reactive oxygen species so that's how
Central
NAD metabolism is to life on this planet
yeah see I mean as you explain it's
involved in so many different processes
and so it kind of raises the question as
how do you go about studying these
different metabolites
well you know I
I grew up as a biochemist
and
um 20 years ago I was really interested
in a particular enzyme called
glutamine-dependent NAD synthetase
and I won't go into why I thought it was
interesting but it has two active sites
you know one of them takes glutamine to
glutamate and mobilizes an ammonium of
all things
and uh the other is called an NAD
synthetase domain
that uses that
um uh ammonium a group to
um to to perform what was then
considered the last step in NAD
synthesis from tryptophan
um from nicotinic acid and in yeast also
from nicotinamide and um I I thought
that enzyme was interesting because it
had two active sites and it had to
coordinate those reactions and it is
required to make NAD which is the
central Catalyst of metabolism and so
you know there's a there's a body of
work to be to be done in that but when I
started learning more about NAD I
thought that there were potentially
unsolved problems in NAD metabolism and
I questioned in fact whether
um tryptophan nicotinic acid
nicotinamide were the only ways of
making Naz and I thought that there
might be a nicotinamide riboside pathway
to NAD and that
use of a nicotenamide riboside as a NAD
precursor in yeast and potentially in
humans
um would
potentially
reveal another Pathway to NAD synthesis
and so I basically I looked for unsolved
problems in NAD and I continue to find
lots and lots of things to work on and
probably the most important giant
category of of things that we're
interested in is the regulation of the
NAD metabolome because you would think
I used to I used to use the terms
um uh the crown jewels of of metabolism
I know it's a week of mourning in the
United Kingdom right now
um but uh but you know crown jewels are
are locked inside of a a safe and put
inside a vault and the vault is you know
uh patrolled by
armed guards and there might be a moat
around a castle right and so crown
jewels are very very protected these are
the central Catalyst of metabolism but
it turns out that NAD coenzymes despite
their crucially important roles are
exposed to what I call conditions of
metabolic stress the NAD metabolism is
not stable to
um
conditions of metabolic stress including
DNA damage oxidative
stress and then I could name you a dozen
physiological challenges and so we're
really interested in how the NAD system
gets Disturbed and then how it tries to
repair itself and then how these things
get altered in disease and conditions
and then what we can do to improve The
Human Condition understanding all of
this yeah so you've brought up many
different points then so one of them
you've mentioned is nicotine noise
ribosides and so it seems to me you
mentioned how you deduce it there with
these like unanswered questions in
metabolism but how did you get about
that deduction was that you listen to
biochemistry and inferred that maybe
that you thought there was some
mechanism that would take you from NR to
NAD or how did you go about this yeah
essentially
um so we there were you know three or
four different lines of reasoning you
know one is that I you know I
grew up as the intellectual grandson of
Arthur kornberg my
um graduate advisor Roberta Fuller was
um was Arthur's graduate student and I
Roberta and I were working in Arthur's
Department of biochemistry at Stanford
and um kind of a legacy of of of corn
bergy and biochemistry goes all the way
back before he worked on uh DNA
replication he worked on NAD synthesis
and
Arthur purified an enzyme I think first
from
a bag of potatoes that you bought in
Maryland when he was working at NIH he
purified an enzyme from potato that
interconverted nmn and NAD
so now we call it nmn adenylial
transferase
um
old school biochemists will study a
reaction in either Direction that's more
convenient to them so Arthur
you know had NAD available to him
so he he actually characterized this
reaction in terms of it splitting
NAD into nmn
plus ATP I think
because the reaction actually goes the
other way right HP and a man form NAD
and amp pyrophosphate so
um
so I knew that there was an enzyme that
would convert nmn to NAD
I knew that
from biochemical activity that was
described in 1950 or maybe even earlier
than that and when I looked at the yeast
genome
I was a yeast person at the time when I
looked at the yeast genome there wasn't
any Gene that was annotated as nmn Aden
allele transferase this is getting a
little technical I should have a
whiteboard here but
um but
essentially there are a bunch of Gene
names there that were assigned to do
particular things
there was genes called anime one anime 2
and they were assigned as having the
activity of taking an amn to an aad
then my enzyme glutamine dependent NAD
synthetase was going to convert naad to
NAD
so as as you know I was would be writing
this on the Whiteboard board it would be
all of these reactions are going up to
NAD from the left side
but animated on the translation would be
making energy from the right side but
there has to be something that makes
sense I see yeah
and
um well I I know there's an enzyme that
will convert nmn to NAD but no one's
described an enzyme that makes nmf
okay so that's one one piece of Empires
then there's another thing there's a
failed cancer drug
I you know you read widely right so
there's a failed cancer drug it's called
tiesofuran
there's another sort of loser of a
cancer drug called benzomide riboside
you you might even come across bends of
my driver's side and the harp literature
both tiresofuran and benzomide riboside
are basically analogues of NR
they've got a base that looks like a
nicotinamide
benzemide
is exactly nicotinamide except
it's a Benzene ring rather than a
pyridine ring
nicotinamide and nicotinic acid have a
nitrogen in a six-membered ring right
benzene's got all six carbons
so
um
and riboside meaning it's got a
ribose linked to to the base
and
um
depends my rib side says if you're in
which is a
sulfur containing nicotinamide analog
linked to to ribose
both of these
um not very effective Cancer drugs
um
are cytotoxic
because they form NAD analogs
well isn't that interesting something
that you can draw on paper that looks
like nicotinamide riboside
and it's super toxic and why is it toxic
because it's making NAD analog therefore
there must be a nixonide riboside kinase
right
and um
and by the way vertebrates have an
enzyme called namped that takes
nicotinamide to enemn yeah so
vertebrates certainly
use something similar to the potato
enzyme that takes sediment to NAD
and no one's described a nicotinamide
riboside kinase invertebrates
now nicotinamide riboside
is a molecule it's been named
okay I didn't come up with the chemical
name for it it even had an older name
than that it was called Factor V
you love it when the old microbiologists
have a name for a factor you know what
factor V came from
uh no I don't I mean there's the okay
the I fight it in the protein context
but not as a metabolites
so Factor V oh no no it's not blood
regulation Factor yeah no no that's a
good question that's a good guess but
it's nothing related to that so so it
actually comes from a
not a flu virus
but a flu-causing bacterium
called hemophilus influenza
hemophilus influenza
and um
now only you know six crazy microbial
biologists in the world want to grow
hemophilus influenza right like who
would do that
and um
why do you think
um and maybe when this is on YouTube you
can pop up a question and have a answer
box or something why do you think they
named this bacterium hemophilus
so well I guess in something instead of
Bloods but
it loves blood right so it actually
needs blood to to grow this this this
bug right so it means you can't grow it
on lb medium you can't grow it on
minimal bacterial medium M9
you you need M9 salts or whatever and
then you need some blood
right so that's where microbiologists
turn into
chemists and biochemists is they have to
fractionate blood and they have to see
what is it in a in blood that hemophilus
influenza can't make on its own
turns out it's two things
hemophilus influenza has a very small
genome it was actually one of the first
um
one of the first bacterial genomes that
was sequenced in the
in like the I'm not sure you were born
literally I think it might have been one
of the first
one or two or three bacteria sequenced
um and Hamilton Smith and and others and
it does not have a heme biosynthetic
pathway so you have to give a heme
and um
it it can't make NAD
from any
normal thing like it can't make NAD from
tryptophan it can't make NAD from
aspartic Acid which most bacteria can
and it can't make NAD from nicotinamide
and it can't make NAD from nicotinic
acid
okay so so initially what had Factor
V yeah sector V what initially had
Factor V activity
was NAD itself
and then turns out nmn also had Factor V
activity and then the smallest
piece of
NAD that had Factor B activity is NR ah
okay so it turns out that hemophilus
influenza will take NR and then it has a
nicotine my driver's side kinase
and nmn a dental transferase to make so
it it has a super tiny Pathway to
enzymes to take the nucleoside precursor
of NAD to the mononucleotide to the
dinucleotide that's the only thing in
the H influenza genome and so so NR was
in the literature as at any deeper
cursor for this like really whack
bacterium
and and I thought well yeah but no one's
ever tried to see whether
um it could be a precursor in a
eukaryote and I have a system now
because I'm mutating
glutamine dependent any descentatase and
if this works the way I think it's going
to work it's going to bypass the
essentiality of of any of these
synthetase because any of these I told
you like you there's a yeast genome
database by now with like you know
assumed to be correct metabolic diagrams
I'm the one that thinks everything's
wrong right so so I uh I don't accept
the diagram as being full and correct
and and neither do I really accept the
idea that NAD synthetase is going to be
essential under all circumstances and
basically we did an experiment to see
whether you can bypass the essentiality
of that Gene
with NR and you could
so NR allowed you could live without
uh naves which meant there's got to be
another way because any of these
entities is required in yeast from
tryptophan from nicotinic acid and from
nicotinamide
doesn't have named and
um and so that was a awesome insight and
then we said now we have the way to
clone the the narcinase because
now if we find the real and our kinase
then that's going to block the ability
of NR
to bypass the
the other pathway this is so you're you
probably have two kinds of listeners the
super nerdy science listeners who are
grouping with all of this and the other
ones that
just want to improve their health and
stuff like that and they're like what is
he talking about but anyway that's back
almost 20 years ago that's how I got
into NAD that's how we found the
nicotine my riboside kinase pathway
and then yeah we always like people tell
us stuff and or we see it in books and
we just say what's the evidence for that
and usually we find it's not entirely
correct and then we find a way to figure
out what is correct
so I mean I think I followed myself
about 75 of that so I think I have to
think
about that but I think you raised a
really interesting point which is about
experimental technique and method in
terms of actually deciphering these
different Pathways and I guess you know
um I believe in terms of how you go
about quantifying the levels of these
different metabolites you use like math
spectrometry but I guess even in that
there's limitations so would you be able
to elaborate on what you think are like
the gold standard ways of actually being
able to quantify these different
metabolites
yeah our our method is the gold standard
okay so um so you need you need you need
um internally standardized quantitative
targeted
um NAD metabolomics and um that was
developed um in my lab our first
publication on it was 2013 with Sam
Trammell
um who is now I think on the faculty in
Copenhagen and
um basically it's a really cool method
um we get yeast to make the
um a C13 version of the NAD metabolome
and then we
um we quantify that yeast extract and
then we dope that yeast extract into any
sample that we measure and then we can
put NAD metabolites on a picamole you
know on a molar scale and um that's
really important because somebody may
say oh there's like a two-fold
difference in some metabolite but if
it's you know two micromolar versus one
micromolar it's almost certainly not
going to be interesting somebody is
calling me over and over again let me
let me let's get a little time out uh so
we do we do
targeted quantitative NAD metabolomes
we're actually expanding our method to
cover
many more metabolites
interesting and so I think another thing
um can you is it mainly looking at blood
samples or like you back with different
tissue samples and in terms of that can
you watery fractionate the samples prior
to your methods to see wow within the
cell these metabolites are so so
um
there's a saying
um the difficult we do immediately The
Impossible takes a little longer
um so uh yeah you can do any tissue that
you want
um and we right now we're doing
something in mice that's liver kidney
and blood
um we've done human liver from people
with alcoholic liver disease done lots
of heart metabolomics lots of blood
metabolomics
um
brain whatever you know CSF any anything
that you want to do we generally
um look at whole blood rather we we've
some Publications where we made pvmcs
but we think that time is of the essence
um and with that what brings up the
exact uh question of
um sub-fractionation so sure you can sub
fractionate
um but then
um what are the controls that you're
going to do that will be sufficient to
say that your let's say mitochondria are
so intact that you know you are really
looking at a mitochondrial and a d
metabolism as opposed to what's left
after you pelleted your mitochondria so
you need complementary methods there's
now
um you know
things that you can do with fluorescence
microscopy that are report you know
reporter groups and stuff like that so
um we we like to collaborate and use
other methods as well
and so I mean
there are so there are limitations with
trying to quantify it but it still gives
a kind of reliable readout in terms of
you see
um I believe declines in NAD Plus for
example in response to these different
metabolic stresses such as
um diabetes Etc as you've mentioned
yeah so
um you know we we've done
um
experiments with you know high fat diet
in in mice and
um
and then induction of type 2 diabetes
from there and you see a um Disturbed
NAD system in the liver
um uh we've done experiments in
peripheral neuropathy Central brain
damage
others have done noise-induced hearing
loss I think some folks are now doing
age-induced hearing loss where there is
a depression of cochlear NAD
um certainly DNA damage induces
um pretty dramatic changes in the NAD
system with parp activation and then
hard activity breaks up the
par polymers and
um so we're interested in all of those
Dynamic changes in the NAD system and
currently I mean um what uh do you think
are the main reasons for this decline in
NAD plus you've mentioned pop enzymes
which kind of consume an AG plus to
perform their reactions but are there
other explanations that might accounts
for the decline
yeah um well and and the first thing is
that
um there's a lot of articles in the
review literature that say
um you know NAD declines in aging and
and I'm always saying you know okay who
measured that and in what tissue and
using what method and so a lot of it has
been storified
and
um we don't really see that
um blood NAD
you know necessarily declines in aging
populations
um the evidence for liver NAD declines
is much better but I think it may be
driven by inflammatory processes
um and so I I always question whether
changes in the NAD system are episodic
and due to specific insults or whether
they're strictly time dependent and I
don't think that it's all that well
established so I always step back and
you know
um
try to talk about what the actual data
say now one of the really striking
cases in which NAD comes under attack in
a disease process is in heart failure
and
um
and it's a strong interest to us because
in multiple models of heart failure NAD
comes under Decline and then the
nicotinamide riboside kinase II Gene
spikes up
and we're trying to determine
um whether it's a low ATP state which
there's some evidence for that
um turns on the nicotinemography kinase
II promoter to try to kind of
homeostatically you know restore NAD
balance or something else but there are
there are a number of enzymes that can
um increase NAD consumption
so when part one and part 2 get
activated and that's usually due to DNA
damage
then NAD can be kind of
um degraded and turned into the ATP
ribose polymer
um in infection and inflammatory
conditions
we've shown that the interferon system
turns on five different members of the
park super family they're monoadp
ribosylating enzymes they're turned on
transcriptionally and then they degrade
the NAD
um seems like it's a response to an
innate immune response to viral
infection and so we're actually trying
to figure out what are the cellular and
or viral proteins that are more related
when
um
when there's double-stranded RNA in the
cell and when there's there there's
virus in the cell there's an enzyme
called cd38 which has multiple membrane
orientations some outside the cell some
inside the cell and some inside the
Lumen of the endolysosome and that can
convert NAD to cyclic ADP ribose that
can then mobilize calcium and lead to a
number of really interesting changes in
in signaling and and cell Mobility
um and then there's an enzyme called
sarm1 and sarm1 basically gets kind of
angry when it sees um nmn and um so
we were talking earlier about enamana
dental transferase and Amanda Dental
transferase
um
in a neuron is located on the outside of
the Golgi apparatus
um so the neuron
peripheral neurons are the longest cells
in your body right so from your sciatic
nerve to the tip to your fingers and the
tips of your toes
and
um that's a very very long Axon
and so that
um cytoplasm and the axon axonoplasm if
you allow me to partially coin a term I
think it's a real word
um
in that exonoplasm is dependent upon the
Golgi localized nmn-at2
and so it turns out that when fast
taxonal transport is disrupted and when
when an acts on is damaged nmn82
[Music]
um you know basically is an unstable
protein this is the work of Michael
Coleman
um in in the UK and and collaborators
and and a man accumulates and then and a
man activates an enzyme called sarm1
and then Psalm 1 can turn NAD into
cyclic ADB ribose and initiate uh well
Aryan degeneration so it's actually very
funny because there are people that
we've shown uh and many other people
have shown that nmn
um
which some people for reasons I don't
understand I think it has to do with
influencers
um
nmn is converted extracellular leads and
R and then NR goes and sells and
repletes the NAD metabolo but there are
people
that think that Enderman magically gets
into cells or gets him to sells through
some transport mechanism but it's
actually been shown that when you push
nmn into cells it activates sarm1 and
that leads to willardian degeneration so
there's just a lot of there's a lot of
messes in the NAD
literature that I'm involved in kind of
cleaning up so before we come back to
some of the you find it's just a little
different topics and then we'll come
back to you but just to start with what
he ended
um as you mentioned earlier like and
I'll can get confides to nmnc how does
that play into if you're increasing in
our levels free supplementation does
that also somehow activate someone
because it gets converted to any men I
don't think so so so
um yeah NR gets into cells nicotine
right ribosychias turns it into animal
Dental transferase will convert the nmn
into NAD then there's nadh hydride
transfer some of the NAD gets converted
to nabp and then then there's the nadp
nadph redox couple
so it's really only in cells that are
um have a problem with nmnat activity
Where nmn will
um
accumulate unless if you had some
liposome delivery or you're transfecting
in you know bolus amounts of nmn then
you could have an nmn problem and that
actually it's been demonstrated
um there's a uh there's an there are nmn
analogs
that our cell permeable unlike nmn
itself there are element analogs that
are cell permeable and those analogs
um because they're self-permeable and
you're it's dose dependent obviously
but if they're not great
um substrates for edamame and dental
transferase and they're self-permeable
then you could have this alarming you
know uh
signal in a cell that there's a lot of
NMM there but I think generally if the
person is taking nmn it's just converted
to NR and then you know the NR is
biosynthetically converted to NAD so
when we do quantitative targeted
metabolomics we can tell
that the ratio of NAD to
things like nmn and NR is like 100 to
one
the it's all in the dinucleotide form
it's almost all of the dinucleotide form
um
what was again it's going to tell you
one more thing but I'm sure I'll come
back to it yeah yeah we fully will I'm
I'm study another thing um I think you
yeah so you mentioned also different
topics so one thing I wanted to question
you on is that I've read how NAD plus
fluctuates throughout the day due to
circadian regulation I'd say when you do
these quantitative measurements and look
at the levels in I guess mice that have
been treated with a high fat diet and or
Not Just A variation like it's in like
the difference between the grapes uh is
that greater than the difference that
you see like in this circadian
oscillation
um
we we were among the people that
established the Circadian oscillation
uh with the late uh Apollo casonic
corsay and
um
and for that reason we always do our
um rodent sacrifices at the same time of
day like right now we're doing an
experiment in which all the sacs are
done at 4 pm which means that if we want
to see a one-hour effect of uh
supplement versus a two hour versus a
four hour versus a eight hour effect of
that supplement it means that
um since all of our sacks are done at
four it means the one hour
supplementation is done at 3 pm the two
hour supplementation is being done at 2
pm the four hour supplementation is
being done at noon and the eight hour
supplementation is done at 8 A.M full
day for for for my um my lab manager and
um because we don't want to have that
um we don't want to supplement all at
the same time of day and then sack at
different times and then have that
overlaid with the Circadian you know
variation which that would be not good
so um uh I think in general I can I can
um assure you that when we've done high
fat and when we've done heart failure
and neurodegenerative experiments we've
been controlled for time of day and
these disease models
um produce you know profound effects
that are much greater than the diurnal
the diurnal variation in the NAD system
okay and I guess like kind of on the
flip side there's also a Time called
like a crano
um medicine where like actually the
timing of supplementation is also
important because the enzymes involves
in metabolizing uh the supplements can
vary throughout the day as well and so
um
do you think there could be time of day
effects whereby there might be a more
optimal time to take something like an
NR supplement
thought yeah
um or or they're they're I guess three
kinds of people in in the world uh with
respect to NR
um most people that I know get up and
take it in the morning roughly same time
of day
um there's some people that
um feel that it helps them sleep better
and so they take it at dinner or the
same time you know in the in in the
evening and
um there are also clinical trials where
they're going to doses as high as two
grams a day where they might be doing a
gram twice a day but um same time of day
is kind of makes sense because it is a
it is a um
uh
circadian function
um same time of day makes sense okay but
no clinical trials so far have had
everyone obviously take out the same day
due to just the difficulties and there's
there's not you know there there's not a
specific clinical investigation of you
know am versus PM effects and you know
like the the strongest effects of
nicotine my riboside that have been seen
in MO the most number of studies are
anti-inflammatory so depressing the
circulation of inflammatory cytokines
like IL 10 il-6 Etc
that I think we showed that first with
Gareth Lavery in Birmingham UK and it's
been seen in in a number of Trials now
um and so that would be the type of very
predictable you know outcome where you
could see whether there's a slight
difference in people taking it morning
versus evening but
um
study hasn't been done okay
and so you've mentioned um I saw a lot
about inflammation and interferon
response and so I guess my background is
Sally lessen Essence which um one of its
characteristics is the senescence
secretory inflammatory phenotype and
there was a paper that I believe you're
one of the co-authors of that came out
either last year or the year before now
where it showed that the SAS the
inflammatory phenotype I believe it
increased cd38 expression on macrophages
and then that decreased energy pass so
would you be able to liberate on that
and explain what that's all about yeah
it's with Anthony covaruvius who's now
um at UCLA I'm I'm at City of Hope so
we're at uh two La institutions and
um so yeah Anthony
um showed that there's macrophage
subpopulations that have high cv38 and
disturb the NAD system and and yeah
that's strongly a part of the
inflammatory response and I you know I
think that that may be what's going on
in a lot of things that you could term
in flamaging so
um so if if NAD is declining
in a uh in the Aging of of a mouse in
liver samples one of the ways to
explain that is that it's a higher
population of inflammatory cells in the
liver it may be that the hepatocytes
um are identical but the percent
hypatocytes are what is altered and that
there's more inflammatory cells due to
either trans-differentiation or
infiltration or
fibrotic processes and those are going
to be some really interesting things to
figure out yeah the show and I the other
reason I brought to office because I at
least I believe like glial cells are a
form of immune cells at least that's how
that derived
um and so I think there's also a study
that showed that cd38 increases in these
glial cells
um in Alzheimer's is that right
it is in fact I had a um investigator
um in my lab on sabbatical
um with a strong interest in
neuroinflammation that is that is
continuing to work on that
so given some of the studies we just
brought up then how would you get about
describing what aging is and the role of
NAD Plus
what is aging Okay so
um
so I think aging is a
um
developmental uh I think aging is
intrinsically linked to development
um and I can defend that in multiple
ways first the strongest
um you know
long-lived mutants that have been
identified in animal systems as diverse
as worms and rodents our loss of
function alleles of
genes involved in growth right so you
know daf 2 and Insulin igf
um pathway and then the pituitary
mutants in in mice including the
snelled work mice and the Ames work mice
and the pit mice all of these
um
genes that encode growth factor and
growth hormone receptor and
growth hormone releasing factor and so
forth and so on you knock out both
copies and you get very small shrimpy
mice that are infertile
and very long-lived and very cancer
resistant
and so you mutate growth
you alter
the course of Aging
um
I have a difficulty calling those
longevity genes because the genes were
actually conserved for growth and
fertility
and in fact in uh the development of of
animals which is what 750 800 million
years of evolution
um animals evolved to
um be successfully born and to develop
the ability to form motility and
acquiring our own food and then
recognizing mates and avoiding predation
and reproducing and either having lots
of babies
or protecting the smaller number of
babies until they're they can
successfully reproduce and some animals
can only reproduce one time in which
case there's really no selection for
longevity and some uh animals can
reproduce multiple times in which
there's a slight selection for longevity
because let's say a fox that can live
six years
um
might have six times as many you know
Broods
pups or whatever foxes have then one
that that that can only reproduce one
time but is that really longevity or is
it Fox cleverness
that allowed it and Fox sex appeal and
all the other things that allowed that
fox to to reproduce
um you know over six years since you
know surviving six Winters it's you know
hunting ability it's a lot of things
so I see longevity the genetic
components of longevity as basically
being emergent properties of selected
trades I don't really see lifespan as a
directed directly selected trades
um there are no dominant longevity genes
that have been identified
um in animals to my knowledge
I have a review article that's coming
out on Friday September 23rd I'm not
quite sure when this YouTube video will
come out but today is September 21 so in
two days from today I have a review
article coming out with over 125
citations the title of which is sirtuins
are not conserved longevity genes I
fully debunk the idea that sirtuins are
dominantly acting conserved longevity
genes from these to
to humans it's just not true
um
The Narrative that sirtuins are the
primary mediators of NAD supplementation
is not evidence-based
um connection between NAD and aging is
that NAD is the linchpin of metabolism
and that our repair capacity and
resiliency declines in aging and many of
those repair and resiliency reactions
depend upon NAD and and all of the
accumulated insults
um involve you know losses to get to the
NAD system so I think there is a use
case for nicotinamide riboside in human
health it may be in fact more important
as we age there's lots of clinical
trials involving NR to test these
hypotheses
um on evidence-based so
you know you don't see a you know a a
supplement bottle you know behind me as
I speak and and you don't you know you
don't see me getting out ahead of my
skis and saying
you're making
um fanciful claims about uh extending
human lifespan but I'm excited about the
clinical trials that are being done with
NR because what it does you know in Road
systems is so powerful
and although we tend to like very
striking quantitative phenotypes like
protection from heart failure so we tend
to do shorter term experiments and then
sacrifice the animals and then look at
mechanisms as opposed to doing two and
three year long experiments and looking
at you know life and death things but
other people are doing those things as
well so I'm excited for the field but I
think that one of the problems is that
it's deeply contaminated
with uh some statements that are just
not evidence-based at all like the idea
that sirtuins or longevity genes is not
evidence-based at all and I and I and
and and and so I think it's it's very
problematic and I spend a lot of time
trying to you know educate people on
that yeah so uh well well said I don't
know yesterday quite a few points again
and one thing I just wanted to quickly
ask you before I forget as you mentioned
about fertility and has have you seen
any of your studies any link between n80
plus
um like levels and fertility because I
know there's a lot of underneath about
in the fertility crisis yeah yeah we
basically started
um you know this the the connection with
with Women's Health and Family Health in
um an experiment that we published in
2019 its ear
um at all
and um in cell reports and um you can
see in the supplementary figure that we
did an experiment with
um
that we did two initial experiments and
one didn't work very well and one was
amazing and so we went with amazing and
then we have a kind of a follow-up but
we wanted to look at the ability of
nicotinoide riboside to
um
you know promote uh
fertility in overweight and
metabolically challenged black six mice
so they were on a high fat diet
and then try to get them pregnant with
and without an r and there was there
were basically only one you know term
pregnancy and it was in high fat with NR
and high fat with NR high fat without NR
couldn't even get the mice pregnant but
you can't do a lot of analysis when you
have one
you know litter
of a supplemented mom and no litters of
non-supplemented moms and you know it's
just so there was that's in a 2019 paper
that NR might be helping Mom get
pregnant particularly if she has
metabolic challenges
but what happened in the normal Chow
side was really amazing you think of
mouse Chow as being very nutritious
stuff and it has all the vitamins that
it's supposed to have in it it's been
formulated it has
B3 equivalents in it and yet the mice
that were given additional nicotine my
riboside did much better they had
um
uh they they're
during the course of their uh
being co-housed with the pops which is
basically the nursing period
um the the mice were uh bigger and more
resilient if the mom was NR supplemented
and the moms lost weight and that were
able to attribute that to Greater milk
production
and it turned out to be linked to um a
better neurodevelopmental
um uh time course for The Offspring and
not only did their motor skills Advance
better if Mom was supplemented
but their whole life trajectory was
better and their body composition was
better
um at three months which is a very much
of uh of an adult uh rodent and so uh
they they could be they could be they
could be bigger at weaning and then they
could be leaner as adults it was quite
remarkable and they had better you know
motor learning skills and uh
Morris water maze performance and they
had lower anxiety scores if you believe
Mouse anxiety scores and so it was it
was quite an amazing thing and now a lot
of other people do are doing things with
with with with with uh NAD boosting in
in maternal Health as well that's really
interesting um so you just looked at
females right oh was there any did you
look at spam counts and males or
anything it was just females I don't
think that our group has done
um sperm count
um that that could be interesting as
well yeah you could come and do it
um I mean reproductive aging is really
really interesting so yeah and it's
something that that it's that there's
very unique features of it in in human
um like the existence of menopause right
so you know a woman half or a woman's
lifetime is beyond her
um
age of reproductive capability that that
I think is because human babies are so
inept at getting their own food and and
being able to be you know protected from
predation that in human evolution we
needed not only mothers but grandmothers
but um so uh so there's some rapidly
involving evolving genes that relate to
to aging
um and then the difference between male
and female is interesting as well yeah I
was about to ask you is there any sex
specific differences just in any of
these
um NL studies that you've done
in terms of like efficacy I guess
not so much that we've done I have to
say that our first high fat thing
um was a male only isn't that terrible
and and
um and then we did the whole then we did
this thing that was all female
and oh but we did look at the pup
um scores and there were male and female
differences in a number of the of the
figures I can't cite you every single
difference but there were some
differences yeah okay but this you think
of something that we should probably pay
more attention to like going on are you
sure okay I sure am now yeah um I'd say
before
um I think we've spoken a lot of in a
lot of detail about uh your scientific
research but I thought because I'm a PC
student web scientist it'd be also
interesting to hear insights um in terms
of Academia versus
um obviously you an advisor I believe
for chromatex which is this um
whether you have the NR formulation and
so how how do you balance that as a
researcher and how do you find
um from my naive perspective being a
scientist but also knowing you have ties
with industry
sure yeah
um and for full disclosure
um chief cybervisor chromadex chief
Scientific Advisor of juvenon which is a
Korean
um company that wants to make NR
supplemented skin products
um and a co-founder of alfina which is
in the cancer
metabolism space I actually worked for
in industry for five years before grad
school at Stanford and the thing that I
learned about it was teamwork
someone very dear to me says Teamwork
Makes the Dream Work and um that that's
something that you know you don't always
see in in Academia
um you have kind of small groups victims
that sometimes compete against each
other and don't communicate as much as
they as they they could
um so um it's great when you come up
with something that could help human
beings that there's a way to license it
and get folks to carry it through What's
called the valley of death and and then
see if they can make a minimal viable
product from it and
um you know see if it is something that
could improve human health or animal
health or something like that so it's
exciting when when you can do it and
um
you know if you have an opportunity as a
PhD student to do kind of an externship
in in a in a commercial lab you might
learn some some cool things
there's many many different types of
um of Industry environments
um I've been in two different ones and
that and then in my Consulting uh life
I've consulted for very different ones
as well as Farm big Pharma so the it's
it's a big world out there there's a
show and um I guess another question I
have is
say there was recently a lot of news all
over Twitter and I think it was like a
nature commentary piece about the lack
of postdocs
um or a shortage of people applying for
pay-stop positions and so obviously now
I'm thinking about potential career
choices why do you see Academia going
and do you see there's going to be some
shortages of researchers going forward
if more are going industry or how where
do you see like the future of Academia
I don't know if I can tell you what the
future of Academia is Elder
um I can tell you that that funding is
getting better in the U.S
um and
um that there's you know a world of
really good projects to work on pay is
getting better for graduate students and
post-docs in the in the U.S
um
I I don't think it's a bad time to be a
grad student or a postdoc
um
in in the U.S
I really don't I think I think it's it's
actually a good time to to be
okay
well that's good to have
to say I say I I some just final
questions uh what are some kind of big
questions or interesting experiments
you'd really like to see be conducted
um like yeah you think either they're
attainable but no one's done it or
things that you would like to be like to
see done but we're we're going to figure
out where nicotine might riboside is
coming from so nicotine right riboside
is a nucleus side like adenosine there's
such a thing as adenosine signaling you
know where adenosine comes from comes
from ATP so so some cell is a NAD donor
basically it's either a lytic process
where the cell's blowing up and the NAD
is being degraded to NR or NAD is being
exported for some reason
and is being degraded to to NR but
there's some type of cell communication
that kind of
um creates the purpose of the nicotine
by driver side kinase Pathway to salvage
that that NR and to be up regulated in
conditions of metabolic stress so that's
something that you're going to see
coming from us you're going to see us
publishing on a rare disease I won't
tell you which one uh quite yet but we
have a very exciting rare disease
project that involves uh the NAD system
and we have a cancer story that's super
cool and we have uh that relates to DNA
repair
and um we're interested in obesity and
inflammation and and uh we'll probably
even do some some
um repair type experiments that that
relate to to problems that that relate
to human aging awesome I study before we
just wrap up do you have any final words
of advice for my fears um who are either
interested in going the
um scientific crates any books or any
sort of recommendations in that area
um or finding advisors yeah the the my
biggest uh piece of advice is
go through the actual data you know so
people are overly impressed with
headlines and with people's
interpretations of things that are
incorrect
um I think people should you know
distrust you know received wisdom look
at the quality of the underlying data
and they're going to find a lot of
really interesting things to work on
and I think it's very important to have
a falsifiable hypothesis
and to have go no-go decisions like you
have in industry and so even though I'm
in Academia
um you know we have falsifiable
hypotheses and we have no go no-go
decisions and we
prioritize our time and resources and
that's what you should do with yourself
because you will have only one life to
give and you know one Eleanor can
contribute to to science and the family
and everything else that you want to do
so
um just you know be passionate and and
don't believe everything that you read
and you'll do great that sounds like
good advice to me so um thank you for
coming on today it's been really
insightful to talk to you I can link as
so I said the best place to direct my
viewers to follow your work or
work sure yeah I'm on Twitter at Charles
M Brenner I answer questions every day
and it was a pleasure to meet you and uh
hope to interact with your audience over
time take care thank you very much
so I hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening